first I want to thank you because I am a
stage 4 cancer survivor and and in my
darkest hours that a lot of people can't
comprehend you were there with me your
voice your everything still to this day
I mean discipline equals freedom is a
common phrase in my family over the most
monumental to the most ridiculous things
like letting the dog out at the same
time you know so I want to thank you for
that with that being said I have at one
point planned my own funeral didn't
think I was gonna be here for my kids
you know the worst part of anybody's
dreams you know nightmares and then
should be at the place where I am right
now and not knowing obviously I'm young
and you know what the future holds
nobody's naive how you've been in those
similar positions just not health wise
but you know facing death and and
everything else how do you switch from
that mindset of like you said when
things are going really bad I'm freaking
awesome
like I kick ass like I really do and
then when things are kind of common like
what do I do now like how am I gonna you
know even when you were just saying like
your last line sometimes I think like
you just speaks to me it's so creepy
that yeah
like I my last chemo was Friday
I shouldn't be well today but I am
because I knew I had to be here you know
so it's like stuff like
and then when you said that you know at
the end of your podcast that you know
I'm gonna live life I'm going to live my
days how did you get from that
transition from you know possibly I
don't know if I'm gonna come out of this
battle I don't know if I'm gonna come
home to okay I'm here life speaking
great let's party and then in between
like did you have any like how did you
do it how did you get from the darkest
places to brightest places and then
bring everything my problem is is I want
to bring I've learned my lesson like
I've learned what I had to have learned
now and now to bring it forward with me
but not to let it define me if that
makes sense for me and I actually gave
this answer to Sam Harris because Sam
Harris said to me you know Jocko you you
you you talk about combat as your
fondest memories and it you know the
best thing that's happened in your life
it's the hype on your life which is all
true and he said but then you talk about
war being awful so which one is it and I
said to him I said have you ever known
anyone that has had cancer terminal
cancer and made it through have you ever
known anyone that that's happened to and
he's like yes and I said when you talk
to them many times they say I'm glad
that this happened to me
number one because it proved I could
take it number two it's better me than
one of my kids and number three now that
I know how dark II can get I truly
appreciate the light in the world
that's what combat is and was for me
that's what it was it was dark and
horrible and I wouldn't wish it on
anyone just like you wouldn't wish
cancer on anyone but if I can give them
a little knowledge a little bit of a
glimpse into what it is just like when
you stand up here people clap when you
said that people are clapping because
they get to see a little bit of it and
they go home tonight and they think what
about that girl what about that girl
she's fighting she's living and I'm
gonna live too
Gansu that's how I look at things now I
don't pretend to have the cognitive
capacity to comprehend the mysteries of
the world
but maybe you're right and maybe you're
here to let us know then it can get dark
but it will get light again absolutely
and thank you